SPEAKER: In our last
episode, we covered
best practices for deploying
and using Cloud Monitoring.
Today, we'll start
looking at best practices
that you can use to get the
most value out of Cloud Logging.
We'll cover how to
ingest and store logs.
And we'll cover the
best ways to query logs
and manage logging costs
in our next episode.
Welcome to Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
[MUSICAL INTRO]
Before we can do anything
with logs at scale,
our services need
to create them.
And they need to be
ingested in Cloud Logging.
We covered the sources
of logs in Google Cloud
in the previous episode,
but let's quickly review.
There's nothing you need to do
to control how logs are emitted
from the platform and network.
But when writing
your own logs, there
are some best practices you
should follow to get the most
value out of that data.
This is where structured
logging comes in.
Consider a log entry
that looks like this,
where the entire payload message
is in a single text payload
field.
If you want to get any
data out of that field,
you have to use regular
expressions or other string
processing methods.
Using a structured
logging approach like this
to create log entries with a
JSON payload field that then
has nested fields under it
allows you to query and analyze
log data much easier.
Every field within JSON
payload can be used to search
and query logs, just
like other fields.
You can even add it to
the logs field explorer
to enable easily grouping and
searching by that field later.
But how do you get
your application
logs to look like that?
If your logs are written by the
Cloud Logging or the Cloud Apps
agents, use one of
the supported parsers
to emit structured logs,
or write your own parser
if needed.
If you're using the
Cloud Logging API,
send a full log entry
structure with a JSON payload.
Finally, if you're using
either the Cloud Logging
library or a third-party
logging library in your code,
make sure you're
using them in the way
that emits structured logs.
We'll link to the
documentation for each
of these in the episode notes.
Writing logs in
a way that allows
you to make the best use of
the data in them is great.
But what's the best way to
store them to balance security,
retention, and access?
Let's have a look at
log centralization,
configuring retention, managing
access, and using exports.
First, keeping your
logs in a central place
helps you manage all your logs
consistently and efficiently.
We talked about
using log buckets
in the previous episode.
But remember that for each
Cloud project, billing account,
folder, and organization,
Cloud Logging automatically
creates two log buckets,
required and default.
You can create
additional buckets
and configure log
sinks that send
logs from multiple
projects to those buckets.
It's often advisable to do this
for audit logs as an example.
Your business needs
and requirements
will likely govern how long
you need to retain logs for.
You can configure
the retention period
for any user-defined
log bucket, and also
for the default log bucket.
Simply edit the bucket
under log storage,
and set your preferred retention
period, up to 10 years.
You can also control where the
logs in the bucket are stored.
You also have the option to
set the location to global
if you don't need to specify
where your logs are physically
stored.
There are two mechanisms you
can use to control access
to logs in buckets.
The first one is
via IAM permissions.
We'll link to the detailed
guide in the episode notes,
but a user will at least
need the logging viewer
role to be able to read
logs in the project.
The second mechanism
to control log access
is log views, which provides you
with an advanced and granular
way to control access to the
logs in your log buckets.
For example, consider
a scenario in which
you store all of
your organization's
logs in a central project.
In this case, you
might want to control
which projects different
users can view logs from.
Using custom log views, you
can give one user access
to logs only from
a single project
while you give another
user access to logs
from all the projects.
Finally, you may
need to export logs
to a third-party
system such as Splunk.
You can do that using
a push-based method
through the Splunk
HTTP event connector
or a pull-based method, using
the Splunk add-on for Google
Cloud Platform.
We covered best practices
for ingesting and storing
logs in Cloud Logging
and controlling log
access, retention, and exports.
I hope these
recommendations help
you keep your services
reliable and your users happy.
In our next episode,
we'll tackle
best practices for analyzing
logs and managing logging
costs.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.
[MUSICAL OUTRO]